hey everyone welcome to the walleye
podcast i'm james marshall and thanks
for tuning in to another episode
and if it is your first time well then
welcome to the show
before i start i gotta have a quick
mention to our three
main sponsors for helping bring this
episode to you and if you're in need of
a late christmas present well then here
are three great ideas
firstly pure sport cbd is a great gift
for anyone who suffers from muscle
or joint pain poor sleep or anxiety
send them some of this stuff and it will
fix them up a treat
fortune favors is a great gift idea for
anyone who loves a great diesel
and manscaped is a great gift idea for
any boyfriend husband mate or family
member who needs to control their body
here
send them one of these things and they
will not regret it
and stay tuned to the end of this
episode to find out how you can
do so but anyway here we go i know i've
said this a lot but i literally have the
number one lad
in the game on today he's playful
japanese clubs honda heat
and toyota shuttles he's played for the
irish powerhouse side leinster
but where he's really made his name is
right here in tasman where he's
represented demarco's on 55 occasions
including captaining the side and now
he's coached the side to
back to back premiership titles he's
also been the assistant coach of the
crusaders winning plenty of
championships down there
it is the goat lad andrew goodman
welcome goodie thanks for coming on
cheers jimmy mates good to finally get
the invite yeah mate i've been um
i was waiting for her for you to go back
to back before we got you on so
i thought you might have been struggling
with a few people mate it's good to be
on here
no looking forward to the story as i
said you are the goat lad
but let's start with the recent um title
back-to-back success how good was that
yeah mate unbelievable you could see in
the box obviously a little bit of uh
emotion there i've got some good
comments around that it's been a
good laugh watching that but um i think
this showed how much it meant
to not only us but the players as well
and uh
it was just real satisfying this year
you know we've had a few up and down
um results during the year um last year
was a little bit different than the fact
that
it starts to seem to align for us last
year there was um
guys like liam and jordi talford that
you know
made themselves available when we
probably weren't expecting to see them
we're real lucky with injuries right
throughout the year and we had a few
friends all blacks that didn't make the
world cup squad so yeah it's one of
those years last year but this year um
early injuries to guys like ethan and
paddy party
then along the way more injuries to some
key leaders like jake norris and druzer
and nanky
and then uh you guys came in and took
their opportunities and
just doped for guys like tim o'malley
who's absolutely out around the team as
you know
and uh for him to come in after
unfortunately hunty went down who's
massive part of our team and to come on
and steady the ship as he did
yeah um no he'll remember that for the
rest of his life and it's pretty cool
working
were you always confident during that
game yeah
and even leading even through the season
were you always feeling confident that
you could do it
yeah like we uh we had some good
discussions as a coaching group around
um
i think the one thing we did do well is
we learnt from all those losses
we um we had some good discussions up in
the
up in the coaches room in in the
leadership group and um
we thought if we could learn from those
uh experiences uh north harbor
canterbury auckland but even some of the
other games where we didn't really
perform to our best
um that we knew we had a couple
performances in us in the end because
you know we've got a great bunch of boys
that uh as you know come in and try and
get better every day and
they are passionate about the jersey and
what have you done about that to
create that culture because obviously
the culture has changed so much from
uh when menu first started back in the
day to what it is now
yeah definitely can't take all the
credit for that i think um
going back to when uh kk and and leon
were first um you know coaching the
group and uh
you know liam was so um like a great
crusader player
50 test all black and he was just so
competitive
um so professional and it just took a
while for
you know him to get across what it
actually took to be professional we
didn't have really many super players at
that stage they were
yeah two or three so to have more and
more super players coming
back into our environment um have a real
core group of local guys that in our
leadership group
that um really drive our standards and
you know the guys that coming in
from outside the region they see how
much the duty means to those guys and
they just buy in because
it's contagious when those guys are um
you know playing with so much uh
passion as the boys like to say and how
massive is the skip
in that sort of sense of david harvelli
yeah what a champ you know
absolutely i've got so much time for
davey and he's a big part of it man he's
a massive part of
the reason why we have um won the last
couple of years
one because the boys respect them so
much uh what he does
on the field but off the field he's so
available to all of them uh
he makes time for everyone in the team
he really really drives our standards
and
yeah i've got a yeah as i said a lot of
time for skip and uh what he's done for
this union
and a couple of um big days afterwards
celebrations how are those
yeah getting harder but i do love it i
do love it i
make sure throughout the season i'm
building brownie points knowing that it
could potentially be a three or four day
at the end of the year so now it's fifa
nina was pretty good it was more max
that was
uh demanding me back on uh on tuesday
after
after the three days but um i was ready
to go the new way
couldn't keep up with the boys on can of
whole golf but now some of the days of
your life say i love that uh
just being able to sit down with the
boys and reflect
have a beer sing a song and you just
connect with the boys in the
coaching team and you've always been
doing that
on the successful side of things ah
you've alwa you've had a pretty
successful start to your coaching career
winning pretty much
everything you've been involved in even
down at the crusaders so
um what do you put that down to is that
just sort of
a little bit of luck or do you do you
take that credit
definitely a lot of luck definitely a
lot of luck yeah very fortunate to
get the call from razer um three years
ago and be involved in an amazing
um set up down there yeah learned so
much and
uh yeah very fortunate to be part of
that um set up and
hopefully bring a bit of that back to
tasman and help keep growing
our union did you win three to everyone
all three years
down there yeah you count the handy
hand of god yeah surely that one doesn't
count
that was before the jackal rules changed
it was clean wasn't it
yeah it's a good game mate i was
twitched up um that game it was
yeah it was one of the most tense games
i've been involved in a box you boys
played an outstanding game that day and
yeah could have easily gone the other
way obviously
play on play on and then you're back
down to the crusaders soon when you have
to go back down there
no it's uh yeah not to after january i
had a day down there
during the week to connect with the
coaching group and strength and
conditioning etc around the pre-season
so
raise is really good um trusting that we
can chip away from our work at home and
we'll just connect over zoom a couple of
times and make sure we're on track for
when the boys come in but
it's quite cool way with all the
everything that's been pushed back the
boys get a good break over
yeah over christmas i know it's not a
favorite time for the lads to be going
back
two weeks before christmas so now as uh
as a whole
everyone that's playing super enjoy the
time with their family or partners over
christmas where they can just
spend a bit more time and chill and
you're happy with the squad
yeah i think it's pretty exciting i got
a um
call well most the boys are coming back
and some real exciting uh new talent
coming through
shafi haki and yeah and the two
uh tight head props um tomati and uh
fletcher neil who are both uh beasts and
they're gonna kick on and be
awesome players short price favourites
to go again or what are you ready for
he's the tank debate some competition eh
some competition man
like you saw it through last year's uh
league anyone could have fed anyone on
their day so
yeah it's gonna be a tough comp again
and it's uh it's a bit of a sprinter
because you've got to be right on you
play new zealand teams every week from
week one yeah
so it's going to be a hell of a
competition eight games two ways
as soon as you drop a couple yeah it's
pretty hard yeah exactly yeah we found
that last year i think we dropped the
first two and then it was pretty much
couldn't catch you since from then on
yeah i think everyone's pretty excited
about
being a final this year though yeah cool
addition to the uh
to the tournament yeah it needed to be a
yeah but anyway let's go back to the
start for a young
andrew david goodman uh what was what
was growing up for you like
yeah it was it was good mate we uh
obviously uh
in tempura for the first three years of
my life which i don't really remember at
all but
um i do have fond memories of uh
rye valley and growing up there with deb
was a teacher and he
was actually headmaster at roy valley
area school so we had plenty of open
space
growing up lots of paddocks to run
around in
the farm over the road where i was
pretty proud of my calf daisy that
won back back-to-back titles i think at
the right value
what do you mean your car best grown car
you know you used to walk the cars
around the amp show you had to go to
after school and groom them down it's a
whole lot of my career
um did you raise that car yeah used to
go over the road every day we'd hope
for a walk give it away groomed down
with the old cone pet cones and
you know we were good mates your only
friend
yeah no but we had um yeah obviously the
three boys and my sister jane and uh
yeah we're pretty competitive in the old
backyard cricket the
roy valley and we had uh the goal post
just down the road we used to go down
and have goal kicking competitions
and tennis and wet golf balls around so
we were pretty active family growing up
and
had lots of fun uh the air tour was
about 11 or 12 before we moved over to
nelson and you're the oldest day
a few grey's coming through against the
hat every day of my life since i've been
18 since i started poking through yeah
cheese cutters hats buckets whatever i
can find really beanies
yeah and then when did rugby start for
you
i was a early starter yeah i started
with a nice four for uh plorus beau
jacks
a local club used to play for so um
yeah used to be a little bit of travel
over to blenheim or uh picton but
mum and dad were really supportive and
used to the old man you know he's a
rugby nut so he used to love it and
mum used to be involved with the old
oranges and after match feeds and
[Music]
yeah after that it was with the nelson
rugby football club after that tap tap
yeah but now it was a good time zay
growing up
playing for polaris and uh yes in like
kahu and those boys come through floris
as well shane i played for flores when
he's young
yeah james king corey holdaway
yeah were you any good
um i think i probably went through
phases when i was young i was
wasn't by all accounts i wasn't too bad
when i was coming through those junior
grades and
under tens and like under 52 tournaments
et cetera
it wasn't yeah i used to go awry and
then kind of when i went to school was
it was
quite a good size when i was younger
didn't have much of a growth spurt after
that and
went to college and got a bit shy on the
old defensive side of things
oh grievo um probably ended up with two
just located shoulders
from number seven to make all my tackles
and nathan meadow
madden it was 12 outside me used to give
me [ __ ] about i'm having to close in all
day to make my tackles as well so
yeah we kind of went through a phase
there uh through college but um
yeah i was i was a battler through
college it wasn't the first thing for
two years but
it wasn't a standout i loved it um
i think probably understood the game
quite well tactically which probably
helped me out a little bit
but in terms of physicality and stuff it
wasn't uh wasn't a dominant first with
gameplay but your old man would have
driven a lot of your
rugby standards out remember he would
always have his notebook
in any game or something it'd always
come and whisper up a wee
tip even to me when i started playing
he'd always tell me the win conditions
or something
are we interesting factor how to beat
this side that we're about to play so
um must have been cool to have him
behind you in all the games yeah yeah
obviously a big part of my life growing
up he was coaching me through uh rugby
and cricket all the way through
cricket used to be crack up he used to
give me um so he's the cat than a
cricket team and he used to
not because he was coach
he used to give me the feels for each
bowler so i used to pull it out when um
joe two was coming into the bowl okay
he's a right arm seamer he needs a bit
off cover
point backward point yeah so i used to
move all the boys around
legsmen are coming on gareth powder he
needs a deep square
so i used to have all these fields but
you know rugby we used to have all the
chat so he
he loved talking uh code and obviously
so did i it wasn't uh
he wasn't a big talker but we used to
just you know chip away we'd watch a
game together and
have the conversations or driving home
from a game he'd
you know just give me a couple of things
that he was supportive but he was
you know he was honest as well yeah um
and he always encouraged the strong
fitness base but still a lot of running
together
it started me doing half marathons when
i was nine i think yeah
i ran it through ran a few of those
together but i retired but i was
thirteen and my buddy hipster
kelly's been no good since but um
you know the famous uh central new
zealand runs he used to make us do
three times up there and he used to be
standing at the others notebook and mark
and he run off
all the boys trying to hide on the way
up on the second time but
it was pretty on today yeah it was it
was cool to have him growing up
being a part of the rugby and qriket
duty yeah and any um first 15 memories
that stand out for you
yeah we actually um we had a pretty good
team we played senior bees back in those
days so we were playing
yeah where the next year the press cup
started up so we were on saturdays we
were playing against all the uh
all the old boys they just wanted to
smash the college kids which is probably
why i was a little bit shy on the ld as
well having bloody
all the big old old boys or the older
guys just wanting to get to the bottom
of the rock and give you a smack going
over to collingwood and
yeah getting a bit of a toweling up at
the bottom of every ruck but um
yeah we made the top eight that yeah in
new zealand which was
pretty good for for our team that year
we had crocky and
a couple of guys have been made been at
school he i think he might have left by
then but
um we had a pretty strong strong team
through our second year first fifteen
yeah
um gregory always reminds me that i've
probably cost us the top four position
but uh
every year i get that from amazed
relentlessly i missed a couple of kicks
on the front field
we outscored um scored wellington
college uh
two tries to one but their first five
brett mauricio was an awesome player
actually passed away young age which is
really sad but he got seven out of seven
uh penalties
we got a couple of tries and i've missed
one or two kicks maybe three
i think we lost 21 19 but um yeah he
didn't
he didn't go the guys that gave all the
penalties away yeah he always got the
gold kicker
no it's good banter every year at least
comes up once a year
and i just got to take it on the chin
did you like gold kicking or did that
sort of put you off goal kicking
no i loved goal cooking yeah i think
just yeah as i said when in rye valley
me and my brothers used to go down and
just kick for the fun of it used to love
to
you know just love kicking a ball around
yeah playing the old kick tennis or
21 or whatever whatever it was over the
posts and um and then we moved to nelson
and i was right over across the road
from neil park so
again used to go over there for hours
after school and just kick balls and
yeah
he was uh dad was actually the one he
gave me the grant fox
video that was my learning for goal
kicking head down follow through
had the old massive run-up it wasn't
until i got over to lentil when i was
bloody
30 that um had actually got some proper
goal kicking coaches and
the guy was like that right that's
horrible that's why you've got the big
bloody
thirst and draw on it you need to just
come back on the 45
and just keep straight through it and it
made a massive difference i was like
man i wish i had this like 12 years ago
you had a massive nudge though yeah i
bet myself from uh
that's where i kind of came like i
didn't mind having those big cracks
because no one really cared if you
missed them or not so
yeah i used to not be afraid to tee them
up from a long way out and uh
you have a crack yeah and then what was
your pathway from college
well i just went down to otago
university
so ever since i was 16 and the old man
had shouted me down to
the mitoten cup final in 1998.
taking on the embankment i was like i'm
coming back here no
whatever it takes it was an unreal day
like that thirty six thousand people
like the embankment was just over full
people just chopping spates everywhere
no one moved like everyone was just
standing and pissing on the bank
this is mongrel but it's awesome went
back to the brothers flat after the game
and uh
yeah there's some good good uh scenes
there for a young 16 year old i was like
man i'm getting back here
so as soon as i left here i was like i'm
coming back to otago what should i do i
was always passionate about um
physical education so yeah i went down
that path and so i headed down to otago
uni straight after school
and uh actually turned up to university
trials because i didn't know anyone down
there really
turned up to university trials and you
kind of turn up this
everyone there that's come down to
university
um turns up to those trials and only got
like 15 minutes at the end and
then you walked into the union they had
the teams named up there and there was
look at that
how do they like pick these teams now
i've got 15 minutes
i didn't do much wrong and i'm in the
like fourth rank
team i was like this is not a great
start were you chasing the rugby dream
then was that what you
still wanted to do trump no i want to
fish no it wasn't about professional
rugby but i thought i was
competitive i wanted to play like good
rugby and then uh this happened to be i
was down at the
lamb reunion field which is close to
university and they're having some kicks
and uh
we'd played king's high school we used
to play them in school every year and a
couple of their boys actually walked
past and
said get out oh hey yum we played you
last year what are you doing for
your club 40 and well um yeah i'm in the
university
fourth string colts team they're like
mate come out to southern uh you know
one of the best decisions of my um uni
career because it was a great club
ended up getting like 20 of us from my
whole cumberland to all come out to
southern that had kind of been a similar
thing that had gone to unicorn
hadn't been that successful so they used
to um pick us up in many events every
tuesday thursday barbecues after
training
yeah but it was just an awesome club uh
great atmosphere down there had some
great do's you know back in the day the
drink at the club rooms till it shut
till you got kicked out then you'd all
go into town and you're number one
yeah now it was good times i love today
southern was a great club for anyone
going down to need
and then how did you get into the
professional rugby side
yeah well so i didn't really make any um
i had a real chip on the shoulder after
that university
i went from being a little bit of a as i
said not a not really aggressive in the
tackle and stuff i got yeah i got a
little bit aggressive
i don't know i don't think that was the
only thing but i grew a little bit i had
a bit of a growth spurt again
moved back and they put me at 12 when i
got to um
southern so i had to be a bit more
physical with that but um
a combination of a lot of beer and poor
diet
plus starting to to do weight so i
actually put on like
12 or 13 kgs in that first year so it
gave me a bit more confidence and uh
didn't make any of the otago 19 teams or
anything like that but my
third year down there i made the otago
development team
so i ended up having three years in that
which was
awesome times had a great we had a
pretty good team with kenny lynn and
callum bruce and
joe sneed and adam thompson on tom dolan
you know those guys come through yeah
in those days he just followed the uh
the mpc team around
so everywhere they played we just played
the curtain roses so i can imagine that
all
23 students together some good times
some good times good nights yeah and uh
we were pretty
yeah so even then i still just yeah
loved playing um just to be competitive
i still didn't really wasn't chasing the
dream
hence the uni i was pretty serious about
making sure i got my degree and
stuff to take away as well but then uh
you know the marco formed you know so it
was
good timing i finished in 2005 my
last year at teachers college and then
demarco started in 2006 and
happened to get a job at nelson college
back at the old school
teach young jimmy mart and uh yeah so
that just happened to coincide well the
timings oh so
moved back to nelson um played club went
back to nelson rugby football club
and um he got amongst it and
[Music]
yeah started really getting got into the
kind of water training group and
started thinking [ __ ] i'd love to have a
good crack at this so so that move was
to get
into the tasman setup now oh it was
yeah i suppose that this coincided well
you know they gave me a ring to say oh
what are you doing
um like no contract or anything it's
like you're coming what are you doing
after you finish the union i said i've
just got a job but
i got the job first so i was moving back
home anyway so um that's your job
you'll jump in the training group and
come to the gym with us etc so yeah that
was
i got um got into that when i came back
up and
had a pretty good year with nelson that
year we um
how gaza stevens was coaching he was a
really good coach
he had a pretty good squad so i made
there was like 32 named so i made major
32
when it got the poster shot yes well is
this the first year the first year first
year of marco so
yeah and then we had a couple of
preseason games and they said they were
gonna
there was going to be two people taking
the score down to 29 or 30. so there's
still three that we're going to get cut
and yeah i still remember getting that
phone call being like
oh man i didn't pick it up the first
time i had a free period had to ring
back and yeah i think it was a beven
that rang at the time and said sorry
mate yeah you've you've missed out
sure i just remember like honestly i was
building my eyes yeah
because i put yeah felt like i put so
much into that you know
you know just being that that close and
then
um first year there was lots of
excitement around first marco team you
know
um lucky enough that you to go on and
play my debut and uh in wellington and i
kind of asked for a better man to mark
than uh
tana and tana and martin and the
midfield so that was pretty cool
but yeah so i got a taste of it that
year and got a big palm off from uh
victor vito
who was like fisher out of school so i
remember turning up to school the next
day then monday because i'd only been in
for the week
for the training went up to play
wellington got on for like 20 minutes ma
tana and ma um first tech or a massive
palm off like
just you know there's one screw in the
chest and like starfish on the ground
and then it wasn't required the next
week so i was back into pe first period
and i was just getting abused every
class i was like
man these guys are ruthless was this
before
victor's body yeah that was well before
but um yeah it was crazy though the
boys that you know you can imagine you
would have been one of them but uh
[Laughter]
just got my day do so it was pretty cool
coming into school but all the boys are
just abusing me i was like
handed out a few detentions that day no
no it's good stuff
let's crack it but then the following
year you obviously um did enough to make
the squad
yeah following year um got back uh yeah
again just trained harder i think that's
one thing that dad did installed on me
was
um you work hard enough you'll get an
opportunity so yeah i always
bet that was something i've always
prided myself on as my work youth i can
had a few uh you know back in the day
that fitness test was always to run up
the center right so
you know used to go up there a lot used
to do a lot of running um
started getting into the weights you
look seriously not keep on building the
body up and got to about 100
100 102 kgs big boy
yeah and just um yeah managed to get
again into that team we've got
probably a handful of games that year i
think um
2007 and yeah and then yeah it's kicked
on from there and
after that started playing a little bit
more consistently at that level you know
it takes a while to get used to it when
you've just come from club and you're
playing
that level um yeah in 2009
kind of yeah so what age were you around
this time you're a bit older right yeah
what about no no i wouldn't i think it
was about 23 24 until i really yeah
really secured a spot in the in the
marco team so
any um highlights from your tasman
career oh there was lots more that was
awesome time i enjoyed
loved playing uh for tasman especially
running out at home
whether it was at lions down or um traga
park and
family there and the old man up in the
stand and um
yeah but some of the games you probably
think about are both around footy shield
games we had
like only two have ever had in the
history
but we put some pretty good performances
in those games like wellington were a
stack team back in 2008 i remember that
game
and we went up there as pretty the team
that have been battling you know
and we put on a pretty good show and we
put that yellow card that khan got that
was a rough call
you're always going to stay rough a
couple of tries to
hose that gear i think at the end of the
game to win that one and then uh the
nike one i just remember
because we knew we had that first uh
challenge of that year so that just
fueled the off season man we were like
right am i knowing that we're gonna have
a
challenge we knew we had a pretty good
squad that year as well
um and then bloody body got released for
one game
one game for that whole year and it's
called like 32 points put on an
absolute clinic and again yeah i uh
yeah so that was like 49 44 that was a
hell of a that was
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was an awesome game but one that i
looked back on i was like [ __ ] man
yeah it would have been awesome to come
on the other side of that and probably a
couple of things there's a cat when you
look back in
as a goal cooker as well you look back
at and question i wonder if that would
have changed the game kind of thing but
um
yeah those were pretty cool experiences
and then um yeah 50th game was pretty
cool getting a blazer it was a
special moment for the for the family
and yeah and what about that try
go on surely that's the career highlight
the best part of that tries again the
old man in the stand when it pans up to
him and the
in the stand on his up on his feet like
massive smile on his face clapping away
like
it was pretty cool to see that um mum
was there with him as well uh
but yeah that was cool it took me about
20 games to get here
first try was that your first try yeah
[ __ ] no second actually i got one
the week before i got into auckland so
it was my second drive but i was
a long way through then yeah uh what do
you remember about that
fluke of a try got a shady ball from
who was playing halfback that they
probably can't get ankles
had a bit of line speed so i got spooked
and then this happened to be a bit of
blind side space and
i don't know how i scored it to be
honest you're quite fast away
you were
oh how good and then obviously the
marco the future of the marcos was in
doubt
save the marco campaign you were a
massive leader of that not many people
know this but um you went worldwide with
your save the marco campaign getting
photos with all sorts of famous people
on an end-of-year tour do you want to
talk about your campaign
yeah so um that year craig moore
um shane booney grieve and myself uh
had saved up we were flatting together
at the time we'd saved up a bit of money
and we followed
um to follow the all blacks around so um
it was coincided with the time that they
were gonna
cut uh four teams which was you know
gutting after
just getting you know just getting
started and feeling like we were making
some progress so it was the save the
marco uh
sign had been made up which had been at
the last few games and so we took a few
of those uh with us on their trip
took about 300 i think and we uh
so i've set the test matches etc we made
sure we were pretty well seen we held
them out to
all the section of the first test my
older brother nick had come in medicine
hong kong as well
um so we had about a section of 50
people um all wearing all black
signs holding up to save the marco got
richie mccor
and uh i think it was lottie dakiri and
a few guys to hold them up after the
game i don't
and then uh i don't know how but managed
to get steve
chu who was one of the people probably
trying to cut the marco
just punked him and just got him on the
phone and said oh my hold this and go
seymour and boys to take a photo um so
this grew mate we had them everywhere
like um had some pretty cool uh names
behind the
behind the save the marco uh poster
there and um
i don't think that was the reason why it
doesn't definitely work steve
[Laughter]
but um you know it's cool that um no
what's happened now i just that the
pathway for
for our local kids the excitement you
can see kids coming through the region
now have a team
playing in the top um competition in new
zealand to
strive for and the pathway on the super
rugby and all blacks now like what
you've seen with
you know dave vavilis and um quinn
strange is the most recent one the
boys that have come through the pathway
and gone on to be all blacks which is
amazing
how good and any other good stories from
that trip
did you get locked in at croke park yeah
yeah
some good go on there's some good yarns
from that trip
yeah so croak park all blacks island
amazing episode
i think it was 85 000 or something at
that game
um me and c moore had got tickets off
ben frank's for that game i think so we
um had some after match tickets for us
afterwards
went up to the aftermath absolutely he
would have been like on you know
who i think why do i give these guys
after match tickets for
like i'm going outside dress going it
wasn't selfies back then on the old
nokias but
seymour was taking photos of me address
that come back to haunt me later in my
career but
um yeah and then we just saw we got
talking to this irish guy who
kind of weaseled his way in there as
well he's just in there like us just
trying to get as much free piss as we
could down the hatch
and um everything everyone kind of
started filtering out
filtering yeah i'm like let's just stay
here as long as we can
and then kind of there was a curt
petition
um and everything just got real like we
kind of looked around there was only a
few people and most of them were
cleaners and we're like
boys let's get a couple of beers and
just go behind this possession and see
what happens so we took like
four or five back there each and we were
so quiet there's like seven away in
these beers
half an hour later we kind of like
walked out we'll have a look
no one there no one like we were walking
around the stadium
going health we're going to get out of
this place man we start started from
like this is pretty cool
stayed in there drinking the beers and i
think we got some top whiskey or
something as well and
having a good crack at that but then we
were in the zone we wanted to go down
the middle of dublin and get amongst it
but we couldn't get out of
the crate it was the pits there was no
cleaners around
couldn't find a security guard man
man this was cool to start but it's not
good anymore ringing back everyone in
new zealand like
just trying to make ourselves bloody
how we get out of here but eventually we
found a security guard who
art
yeah it wasn't good it was good at start
but i usually say you're like
after a while you just want to get
amongst the atmosphere again disastrous
and they're having a
having a beer yeah anything for a free
deezer yeah exactly
you know what it's like managed to take
a few free diesels in our time oh yeah
let's go to our wellington seven stays
and even our hong kong seven states
we had a few good um trips up to
wellington especially yeah
team tiger was a highlight i think the
tug of war team yeah that space kit we
got it this worked out well we
what if we had a big 10-man rope and
then like a took another smaller
2v2 right yeah didn't watch my sevens to
be fair
but we had a lot of uh challenges for
the old tug of war
been unbeaten and we used to fear a yap
a just an act
only with the toothbrush used to be the
rule tonight and yeah pretty feral by
the end of the weekend but
yeah some amazing times that's a shame
that uh that kind of
faded out it's a good weekend um
remember dan hyatt got thrown and said
he got thrown into the water right
classic wallet and everything in his bun
throw it in the water oh good stuff i
think he got a bit lucky after one of
our wednesday and
boys took a section toward him threw him
in it was good stuff
and um he made the tv after that right
he's 10 7. that was one of the best
highlights of my life really just
sitting at home one night at the flat
with seymour and booney and we're like
that's kobe like and his team
team bum bearing on sloppy as walking
around
face blew it out clear as they kahu
though anyone that knows car who knows
it's him
and the commentary over it's like this
it's clear this joy is not just been on
alcohol
he's on some substance but around that
knows who knows that's this was
after a good night on the bears and had
um
yeah so that night he ended up going
into the a e was on the drip for a bit
[Music]
and he turned back up at the flat that
night remember he had to like the
drip hanging out of his arm still he'd
like discharged himself and ran out of
the hospital
and he had the little they must have had
a towel over his forehead he had the
little towel from the hospital around
his neck and the
iv line still hanging out his arm it was
so good
oh geez he must have jumped chunks
yeah mate that was closer
and you'll also have the record for the
worst dresser
to see let's do it yeah rubik's cube it
was a good idea at the time i thought
the old rubik's cube but it didn't
really
really no one really bought
yeah it was actually it worked out well
because there was a dodgeball set up
outside the um
stadium that year so yeah of course we
were in there all day and did you get
what year did you go up as victor's body
double or did you
just change your kit that was with you
he wasn't i knew i can't remember
yeah i don't know do you still reckon
you've got a body locker
no oh
good times oh anyway let's get back to
the rugby
so tasman you didn't get it you never
got a super gig
did you ever get close um there was a
couple of little opportunities they like
um
toddy rang me up i played a reasonable
season in
2009 yeah for the market probably one of
my best years for tasman and then
so he rang me up and had a wider
training group
opportunity for me which i was yeah
stoked like i was like
[ __ ] yeah here we go why the training
group get me down there i'll work hard
it's a little bit different but then it
was more of you know going as
going down as a bit of a training body
but i just thought [ __ ] i just want an
opportunity
yeah get me down there but then like a
day later this contract came through
from
japan and i was like holy the guy kept
on talking about it and yen and i was
like
that sounds like a lot of money but i
don't
have a like phone or anything near me
it's a computer to check whatever the
conversion was and i kind of got off the
phone call afterwards and i was like
converted it over it's like
that can't be right like i was only back
then at tasman the minimum was like 15
and i probably was the third year and i
think i was only on like 22 or something
yeah this japanese money was just
ridiculous
it can't be right i had to bring back
the agent who'd rang me up i was like
mate what was the sum again and there's
like yeah no that's after tax as well
like that's what you'll get in the hand
i was like
man this is crazy man and i told dad and
he was like
oh that's awesome that they've um
noticed you but you still gotta go
crusaders yeah
i was like yeah yeah yeah and i was
thinking [ __ ] and i was like in a real
pickle for ages i just trying to decide
because
i had a big student loan yeah
um yeah i knew crusaders had a stack
team wasn't although i wanted to go down
there and prove myself wasn't
too sure if i was going to get an
opportunity yeah rang up toddy toddy was
awesome about it i actually flew up
i remember i've got a lot of time for
tony i flew up to nelson and
sat down went up for lunch and went
through all the pros and cons and
and then he called me back the next day
and said mate i've worked that you can
come down and
still do your japanese thing after so
come down
yeah just get it all over the line with
your japanese club that you missed their
preseason
and um you can still come down i was
like man so appreciative of that like
thanks a lot toddy a lot you can still
get all that yeah yeah
get a chance go down to crusaders i was
only going to go for a year because
um at the time i yeah because i didn't
know with tasman coming back and or not
yeah and then um yeah ring up the
japanese club and then
we want to use you as a team as well so
you've got to be over here to help
organize our
team yeah i was like man
back through for a couple of weeks
trying to decide what to do and dad was
like still writing these massive notes
saying i think the crusaders
get down there prove yourself and i'm
like [ __ ] yeah i know
i know but then toddy came up and said
mate let me look at the contract
you've got to go yeah just go like the
wider training group we've got these
guys there's going to have to be all
these injuries before you get an
opportunity so yeah i really appreciate
toddy for being honest around that yeah
signed the japanese thing dad gave me a
bit of a frown but he got around he
understood
when i bought him a new tv in the fridge
he was stuck
and then um yeah so it gave me an
opportunity to
you know pay the student loan off get a
big deposit down in the house which has
set me up now you know
i still look back and think [ __ ] what
could have been because um before i went
to japan
the crusaders that yeah played their
first game in uh in
a pre-season game yeah and actually
they've been two injuries quite bad ones
and
tom taylor who got called and when i
didn't go in the wider training group
was starting that game and i was like
man
i was thinking you know you had those
doubts about if you've made the right
decision so yeah
but anyway then yeah went over japan
enjoyed the year um and then
tasman got confirmed back into the into
the comp and yeah
signed it back up with tasmania how did
you find the lifestyle over in japan
yeah i really enjoyed it uh nene came
over
here yeah and then he came over and um
we would enjoy today like she'd studied
a little bit
at school so she had a little bit of
language behind her
but love the food i'm a big food man
yeah got really really
into that yeah raw chicken
oh uh and so all that kind of stuff and
yeah the boys were really cool they were
welcoming a good bunch of boys they
enjoy a beer
yeah two hours all you can drink and eat
i used to annoy me
just get in the zone you want to go out
and carry on though
go on you're like what yeah so
um solo character karaoke but um yeah we
were in a bit of a
i suppose a lot of countries well it
wasn't much going on but you know well
it's life over there just get on the
bullet train you're in tokyo or nagoya
and
yeah it's cool to travel around and
experience a bit of a different culture
and then back to tasman yeah back to
tasman um
2011 we had a tough year that year i
think a wooden spoon
but kind of leon come on that yeah leon
and kate
you could tell they were building
something and we had that same crew
coming back the next year and we
actually had an awesome year in 2012
really like we started that's when we
started to really build we um
we were still a little bit inconsistent
but we beat some of the bigger teams
um made it to the semis probably should
have been in the final but we got
held up by harbour who were down the
bottom of the table and just to show our
um
inconsistency the week before so we
missed out on the home semi then we had
to go down to otago and
they put this down there so but you know
that that group
majority stayed together the next year
and ended up winning the championship
which was
although it was awesome to watch it was
also really hard i was over in ireland
by then and
you know i start absolutely stoked for
the boys but kind of like
homo hard wishing i was a bad hero one
just because we've kind of been building
that i knew that bender was going to be
unreal but um yeah just to uh not just
to see the boys i was stoked they
um see shona pick up that trophy um it
was it was a pretty cool feeling
talk to me about the um island call yes
that was a bit of a random one really um
had again had a not too bad year in 2012
and that's when i
got a little bit more interest for super
so jk had kind of rang me up he was
taking over the blues i think that stage
and
just asked if i was available didn't
offer anything or anything it was just
checking around it and then
yeah a couple of days later i got a call
i was rushing out to um
i can't remember what school i think it
might have been naughty mother or
something
country yeah coverage was kind of
breaking up i was just getting on the
borderline out there it's like one or
two bars
had this call when i was running a bit
late and i thought it would have been
the headmaster out there wondering where
i was yeah
so i kind of picked up it was a random
number i couldn't kind of hear and i was
like yeah yeah mate i'll be there soon
i'll be there soon and there's like no
no no
the guy was like no no it's joe smith
here
[Laughter]
joe smith i'm calling from ireland and i
was like oh
joe how are you island [ __ ] yeah so i
kind of pulled over and
i was trying to look for some bars i was
like cruising up the side of the road at
like
20 car an hour trying to find a place
that had some had some good reception
and he was like mate i'm uh over here uh
coaching and uh just wondering if you
might be available to come over
and i was like man yeah at least i loved
it we're like loveliest i'd love to come
over and play for you
awesome like peeking like out of nowhere
you know
yeah and he was like oh no leinster
lindstone oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah but no it was a classic
it was a bit of a funny conversation we
laughed at it a few times when i got
over there and saw joe but yeah forever
grateful
for uh to joe and minster for giving me
an opportunity because
it was kind of that one thing after
playing what attended i just wanted to
test myself at the next level yeah
i knew i knew i'm never going to get to
international or anything like that but
thought i um could have been you know it
was worth maybe having a crack at super
but
didn't get that opportunity and to go
over to ireland and play for such a club
like leinster
and get to playing some big horner and
cup games against claremont
mark rougeri and for farner driscoll and
darcy and outside sexton was
i was happy then i was like i've gone
over i've had a crack at that next level
and
proven to myself that i can do it you
know yeah so i was um yeah
as i said forever grateful and it was a
great experience was it a hard
hard um decision to leave [ __ ] no not
easy that would have been like this is
the easiest signing ever i was pretty
much like
didn't have a kind of real agent then so
i was like send me the contract i'll
sign it
like that would have been like [ __ ]
let's just label this guy hard
because they just sent it over didn't
even read it realized i sent it back
like
got over there i was asking like kind of
got mates with a couple other guys i was
like
what kind of corny and i was like [ __ ] i
could have
could have actually got a bit more if
i'd had an agent maybe but i didn't care
man it was such a cool experience and
such a great uh club to play for and
yeah
awesome uh again nina came over we made
some awesome friends and uh
got to do some amazing travel yeah what
were the lads like what was
adresco and sexton like although awesome
guys like um
as you can imagine they're really
professional um
but the island island needs a great
crack is it what they called it over
there
good banter it was a different level of
banter because leenster was um
it's quite a private um school game over
there in
dublin all the boys are really well
educated
and uh they have good banter real good
banter in the changing room but some of
the banter was
a bit above me they started talking
political banter and stuff i was like
man
i was just seeing the corner real quiet
there was some
switched on dudes but they were all real
uh welcoming i was probably actually a
little bit shy like i was
going over there i knew there was a lot
of internationals yeah like
usually the foreign signings are you
like easton and thaiwa who is like a god
over there or that had rocky elsa and i
was just like a battle from tasman
coming over i was like
man i was gonna put my head down here
and work hard and just
prove myself like i didn't want to go in
there and be a big
big mouth it was just yapping away and
beside us
i was probably looking back and i was
probably a little bit shy at the start
and
yeah didn't really put myself out there
which was a little bit about a little
bit me but
um just tried to work hard and they were
great i've made some good friends and
once you had a couple of nights on the
old uh on the old guinness you know
the real guy came out and got me got
nude and uh
made a fool of myself and uh it was gone
from there actually my first night
i played my debut against ospreys and we
flew back from wales you know you fly
back after the game yeah
and all the international threw away at
that stage and so it was mostly academy
boys
the the club had given me like a
a cash um ford afforded me some cash for
um my bond i was moving into my
place a couple of days later oh yeah and
i had like 700 euro in my wallet to pay
this lady for my first
week or whatever it was for the bond and
we ended up going out for a night in the
lash
double after my first game woke up the
next morning
all gone i was like [ __ ]
what has gone on here like i've had an
absolute shock i've either lost it all
or i don't know what's happened i got to
training on monday the academy board's
like oh you're a good man like
[ __ ] you're buying trays and trays are
perfect
oh man i had to go back up to the
manager and say mate can i please have
another loan because i
need to pay that bond and i spend all my
money out in the piss the other night it
was like looking
like oh if we signed here i remember
ringing out nina and she was like you're
an idiot and i was like
yeah but they got it got on with the
academy awards after that
got in yeah oh that's crack up
any um games that stand out for you over
there oh definitely um
the back to back against claremont um
those two games um so the first one was
that um
over in france just the atmosphere over
there like driving up to the game
they're crazy rugby over the years
because you know
like chanting and seeing like the the
cold crowd it felt like was
outside the bus as we pulled out yeah
and they loved linster as well so they
were real
good supporters of rugby yeah but they
were like um going and there was only 21
000 people there i think so it's
even then that was the biggest crowd
i've played against but they're right on
top of you yeah
i was the only uh non-international back
in both
teams they had like sadovini and then a
full french like morgan parra and um
as i said rogerie and fawfana and i
can't remember us at fullback but we had
like
all the irish boys but luckily yo triska
was injured uh for me so i got to
jump in there with uh dars in the
midfield
it's an amazing game mode like i was
just like holy [ __ ] i've got a man up
here
bloody this is i remember thinking jesus
i'm not supposed to be here
how'd you go yeah i've been a writer a
lot i quite liked joe's way of playing
he was
pretty structured but if you just nailed
your job which for 12's over there was
just cutting hard first phase
for darcy so i was just uh y'all just
concentrated my role
went not too bad that game and then the
next return feature was at um
aviva so again 55 000 people this time
in front of
all the irish fans like it was just
crazy
yeah and then i suppose the other one
was monster down at thurman park like
had a good win down there real tight
game mum and dad were over for that one
and i was on the bench but dust got
injured in the first
five minutes oh true you're not really
ready to go up
my feet going [ __ ] going the old high
tuck jumps that i used to do
running on the headless choke for the
first five minutes but i was settling
into it playing with o'driscoll
was awesome he ended up scoring a try
rod on full time i think to win
it was just an amazing atmosphere just
like the whole silence for the goal
kickers and stuff was
just something different eh amazing
football rugby supporters over there so
now it was pretty cool to get the one
there and to have mum and dad over there
as well
that's her thing and then from from
ireland
what was where did you go to next did
you go back to japan yeah
tasman no so i played that first game
with uh first season with leicester and
then um
the start of that next pre-season joe
had left to coach island matt o'connor
had come in
um and yeah i knew
i only had one more year on my contract
i knew i had to have a big year to try
because it was something
a place i saw myself potentially staying
for a few years we just settled in and
loved the club loved the city boys were
awesome
travel was great around europe so we
were really keen to settle down over
there for a little bit so i knew i
needed a big season to impress matt
and get another contract but i ruptured
my kelly's like
in pre-season had like a real bad
tendinitis and
ended up getting an injection which
wasn't the best thing and
the trainer actually said to me mate you
need to get off like you've done your
yards and i
was just like i just want to do a couple
more you know
ruptured it and then uh yes that was a
disappointing way to finish over there
but
i still did the whole year with them
they uh credited they looked after me so
well man
paid me the whole time yeah where they
could have cut it down a little bit i
think they sent me over to sweden to
kill his guru to fix me up rehabbed me
and then
gave me time off during the year to
travel so i mean they never was
full-time tourists really going for
italy and france and croatia and it was
an awesome year apart from not
obviously not being contributed on the
field like the amount of travel and
stuff we got to do was pretty amazing
and then um
yeah i was flying back to new zealand
just going to come back and play club 40
for nelson again and try and
crack the marco which i knew would be a
tough ass because they
had pushed on since i left and there
were some good players there tojo and
a few of the following and they were
playing really good footy yeah and then
i got a phone call
when i landed and i think we'd gone
through
l.a or something so we're in transition
and um
an agent rang me up i know uh coach ran
me out from japan and said he came to
come over
to japan again same coach that i had a
honda but a different club so
it's like mate yeah i've got nothing
guaranteed so yeah [ __ ] yeah get me over
there
so i flew to nelson and then the next
started to get back on a plane and fly
to japan
because they were real sketchy about my
achilles
yeah bad injury i had to go over there
and run the
they were doing fitness testing two days
later the whole team so to go over and
do that with them
got i think i've got a second or
something so you know big test under
pressure i was like
empty the tank attack this is for yen
i'm just gonna empty it here
empty the tank so i went hard this we
got through that
um they'd done some really like
one-on-one skill testing and stuff with
me like
punting and goal kicking and passing and
stuff which was really pretty random but
yeah
nailed it i think
unfortunately after about five games
just before my sixth game
uh you know medical you get six gains
we'll give you
this extra money that's true done the
old acl not that it was all about the
money over there i was again it was
somewhere cool like we moved to
the little place that we moved was just
outside nikoi and it was again pretty
cool little bunch of foreigners
uh the evident again somewhere i thought
meanie were like well we could stay here
for a couple years you know
finish off but then the acl like yeah
five games and was
disappointing i was like man from
someone who had no injuries right
throughout and then to double bang
achilles
acl recovered you know rehab came
still going to play for the marco next
year came back to nelson
keiko was like you can't come back after
achilles in a acl
that made me train even harder yeah
trained with glenn got me in real good
nick
gave me an opportunity in the preseason
and then uh
first came back first minute dislocated
and broke my finger real badly
rolled me up for most of that season so
ended up playing a couple of games off
the bench at the end of that season but
that was it
quite professionally for me ringing kind
of at the end of the end of that season
was like
you want to come into coaching i was
like man i was going to have a crack at
making this team again next year
so i kind of took the hint and you know
again really grateful for um
for that opportunity because that's led
on to some pretty cool opportunities for
myself and
so was that always the plan for you to
coach get into coaching well i kind of
always again just you know through uh
dad
said night coaching could be something
you do afterwards so just make sure you
take notes and
yeah you know be aware of what's going
on around you and
even that second year i was injured at
length he was real good around
go to the trainings watch how they're
doing things go and watch the forward
see what they're doing yeah
go to make sure you're on all meetings
and taking notes and stuff so that was a
good advice from him and
um you know i had that teaching
background anyway and i was doing a lot
of coaching right throughout
when i started teaching first 15 and age
group rep stuff so
it was something i was keen to get into
but i didn't know it was going to happen
kind of that fast and um and be a career
career option for me yeah so this was
the following year you were straight
in the tasman setting yeah so i got the
opportunity through that tasman set up
and um
they kind of said yeah it went through
the interview process which was a bit
daunting but they
at the end they said you've got the job
and i said cool um
it's awesome thanks a lot but i want to
play one more year for nelson club
oh yeah oh it's probably not a great
look if you're playing for nelson and
coaching guys during the week and
part of your role was to go around the
clubs as well i was like man i want to
get my blazer for nelson you know
what 10 games away from 100 so it took a
bit of convincing
and looking back it probably was a thing
that the club's probably wasn't great
but i was just going around doing
skills stuff it wasn't like i was going
in there and getting their structures
and stuff on the thursday night
i was pretty crack up like marking nancy
and stuff on saturday after training
with him on wednesday yeah there's a bit
of banter going on there but um
no i really enjoyed that final euro like
just playing for fun
uh playing with a lot of guys that were
coming through like davey and quinn and
ethan and those guys it was awesome yeah
man and drop goal to win again yeah we
went
won the tasman trophy which was cool and
it was just a way for me to finish get
the 100 game blazer and
yeah and how have you found coaching
yeah i've loved it man like it's
so good you know i love the game and
it's been some transition
it's a lot of hours a lot of a lot of uh
long days away from the family but
you wouldn't have it any other way you
know like yeah i also really like it the
other side of it you get to
have this time now like extended break
to spend with the boys and
nina and the wider family and friends so
uh it was at the start it was like going
back into coaching tasman and a few of
your mates are still playing you're
wondering how this is going to go but
yeah again i've just tried to whenever
i've gone to summer i've just tried to
work really hard and
earn respect that way yeah you know be
vulnerable and
pretend like you don't know everything
ask questions and i
think i'm a coach that uh you know tries
to use those guys around me because i
know there's so much knowledge
especially going into the crusaders i
was like wow
yeah first time i head down there i was
like man should i be here like
kieran reed and white lock and crotty
and richie and i'm just like
far out remember that we had a all the
all blacks had come back and so
razer was meeting them to introduce our
new coaches and just a few things we're
going to do for the year and i was like
i had to get up and introduce myself i
was packing myself yeah
and the first few times i got up in
front of the team man i was nervous as
anything but
i think it probably took just a reader
to come up and say man it was good
real clear key things we need to nail
like and i kind of got real confidence
from something like that yeah
and just you know again just try to work
hard
get alongside the boys have
conversations with them get to know them
as
as people as well and yeah you realize
that everyone's just wants to get better
and
yeah there's no no real egos and in the
crusaders or tasman so it's this
you know pretty collaborative um
coaching approach
to use whatever you're doing it seems to
be a working horse
well what's the plans going forward have
you got much of a plan
um i've got to plan for the next couple
of years i've got another year with the
crusaders
um and then i'll do uh one more year
with the tasman like
this was kind of we were thinking i said
nina was like you can't keep doing both
forever like yeah
but i just love coming back here i love
coming back to tasman such great
buildings for boys and
to sync with um you know a couple of
uh with dermo leaving uh this year after
being awesome for us man he's done a
great job with our forwards um
and shania doing his hard on his job now
and potentially gonna be as last year i
thought it would just be cool to
have one more year and um yeah get a
hopefully get another job done next year
you know get come back and we've got a
good squad coming back again next year
and it's exciting that there's some
a couple of awesome sightings i'm
looking forward to seeing go like jimmy
the jet
the difference jim beam he's got so many
nicknames now the career
this guy's like max hicks that are um
who's with us most of the year this year
he's going to be a good player like
played well for marist he's um hopefully
he's got a lot from this year and he'll
go away and have an awesome offseason
and come back and be
you know marco for a long time so
there's some good young players coming
through away
as he saw mark he's coming back and
making springer from waimea those boys
that are coming through
um first year next year they're not
going to be marco next year those young
boys but there's some
awesome local talent coming through that
i'm excited to see in the years to come
yeah how good what a career and what a
journey
but as always we've gone to our
instagram for some
questions we'll have a sip of this
fortune flavor before i can please
you better finish it you got that many
questions
first question this is a good one if he
could give just three pieces of advice
on building a winning team what would
they be
and that's deep man it is go on
you're expecting those questions three
things three
it's all about the people's number one
you've got to get to know the people you
gotta connect the group
um one thing i've really learned from uh
from razer and the crusaders group is
you've got to
make sure that everyone can be
themselves in your environment you don't
want clones
you want everyone to be comfortable in
their own skin not coming in and
being themselves yeah and i think the
enjoyment making the environment as
drawable as possible i think that's what
we do really well here at tasman
the boys love coming into work every day
they don't we don't call it work but um
but a banter with bruce um a bit of fun
you know
don't make it uh repetitive and you've
got to keep the boys engaged yeah
that question was for me
okay how stiff should a fins up be
crossing the chalk
it's got to be it's gonna be stiff mate
i've
seen uh nina's been actually
in the crowd a couple of times like
pretty passionate fun she's been putting
up it's been a bit
bit loose though dwayne's was quite
stiff yeah i like dwayne so you've done
a good job i was proud to see him do
that
yeah yeah now you've got to be it's
going to be a proud this the marco
struck [ __ ] strong
he's got a strong feeling so i think
yeah pretty stiff
pretty stiff when hunt went off in the
final did you consider putting the
jersey back on
no no no i uh had faith that we had two
good men out there that were gonna
could do the job there was obviously uh
dave who's really comfortable at 10.
yeah and uh man bruce who's um
you know been around three or four years
in the team now he's only had limited
opportunities in that ten jersey but
um yeah stoked for him to come on and as
i said start to um
and you know the work that dave's under
extra responsibility he took and yeah
they both done an awesome job at
controlling the game after hunting him
off
if if you went on derek and you still
would have won the fight
no
yeah what happens if your body held up
they would have been up mate of course
it could have been a strong fit up as
well
is it true you have the smallest calf
muscles in the team oh
um the corners are pretty small come on
there hasn't been a lot of leg weights
to be fair i'll give them that one
when i go to the gym these days it's
either
yeah i do a lot of big stuff but not
much car phrases so i've taken that
feedback on board there's
been a lot more leg work over the last
few weeks
getting on the razors yeah okay most
expensive tab you've ever had to pay
that was probably
yeah yeah
links to one but there's one at the
mountain sevens one year when we
had a fake tab going you were there we
put it on room 365 i think it was and
got away with it for about four hours
before they
found out but we managed to do a run
from that one sorry ended
sorry for that behavior whoever that was
but hopefully the hotel took that one in
the room didn't have to pay it off
that's right it was
how many hamstring sleeves and
protectors have you owned in your life
well they were pretty loyal those two i
had they lasted most of my career man i
used to get a bit stuck for those i used
to
the old thick sleeves they were good
though mate bit of deep heat under those
good old warm up get the they were like
they stuck as wet suits they used to be
a dirty old sweat underneath my
game but they done the job did you have
heaps of having issues or whatever no
just after the fashion
this the end of the career after i've
done the acl the old hemi the hemi on
that left side especially got real weak
and then
must have overcompensated in the right
when a couple of times
yeah it wasn't good okay
in your professional opinion do you
think will jordan is better than michael
jordan
yes he's a good player will how good was
that michael jordan documentary though
but yeah will's uh
he's a special kid man he's gonna have a
massive future i'm looking forward to
seeing uh
more of that uh 15 minutes we saw in
that last test match yeah you should do
a docker on well
okay favorite win when you were at the
marcos
favorite one i would have had to be now
our first win over auckland um i think
it was 2008
trafalgar park 12 8 yeah it was a good
good day you know
first time we'd be in uh yeah auckland
and
to do it at home and there's a hissing
crowd that day afternoon footy
and it was pretty special yeah good call
who's the number one ranked golfer in
the goodman family
chris has been playing every day he's a
cheat actually it's tied we've got a um
since the old man passed away we played
for the green his green
cd presence jacket every year so yeah
kahu's a part of that
and he's actually the the current holder
okay so
um we're won a piece over four years so
the next time we play is going to be uh
big coverts put a bit of a stop to it
this year so we're waiting for nick to
come back from career and we'll uh
have the decider and that will that will
tell the story
would you consider naming your third son
bruce
definitely mate it's already been a
conversation for the first for the
second one you know so
definitely bruce is going to be he'll be
right up there mate
uh most difficult player to coach
oh mate that's that that's a stitch up
um the most difficult player to coach
it's got to be shane christie
and that was when i was kind of player
coaching at um
at nelson rugby football club again he
was he was a nightmare
when he young shane christie the people
that remember him the
turnaround that he's made now to how
professional et cetera he got but
a young shane christie was a nightmare
yeah
okay who's the player you've witnessed
and proved the most while coaching them
uh
pretty cool story this year considering
uh
you know he probably didn't have the
best club season by
all accounts uh watching that and had a
bit of issues with the weight but
he worked really hard towards the end of
that club season with uh jimmy holden
and
uh mate to play everything he got the
most minutes for us this year and was
awesome mate played some good footy so i
was stoked for tea
good answer what's the best thing that
happened to you in
2019
oh is that from nina yeah
you know you got me there yeah i better
say yeah
the marco i'm busy season definitely the
birth of my second
son quinn goodman didn't really got me
though
but when you you you gave it away
actually a few questions
sure shouldn't i say that is that a
running joke
yeah yeah you said it a few times it was
a you know i've messed up that one a
couple of times
okay is it true you can pick up a tennis
ball with your toes
yes incredibly long toes
hence why i don't get seen in general
too much only wearing people i'm
comfortable around
they're pretty freaky these things but
um yeah i can bother
leg spinner i haven't quite mastered the
googler yet but working on it
um can draw a pretty good stick figure
pretty handy at your dinner yeah
everyone in your family got long tails
yeah the moriarty side so mom's side
there's some pretty long toes on that
side of the family
yeah that's good stuff
with such a time-consuming role how do
you balance work life with
a young family yeah it's tough eh um i
struggle with it to be fair i haven't
quite got that right yet
um and it's it's tough with max he's
three and a half now he starts to notice
it a little bit more
when you're gonna be home from work and
struggles to see you leaving so it's
something i've got to work on and
make sure that when i come home i just
don't get the laptop out straight away
it's so easy to think about something on
the drive home
yeah you want to sort it out straight
away have a look at it
or um yeah so get some time under there
make sure you spend time to kick the
ball around or read a book or
you give them the beard you know yeah
nene got him again
stitch up she's gonna hold me
accountable
[Laughter]
okay do you credit any of your coaching
prowess to the fellow godfather
peter gregg oh of course mate it was an
early um
early mentor to me he taught me all
about team bonding and
getting the boys together for a beer now
he was good i love greg
he was pretty cool through uh school as
a coach
yeah again he um and like uh
he just made the boys feel comfortable
we had a good time with the lads he was
approachable and no he's a good mate
googie so yeah
definitely loved this pre-game speech
it's one of the great one of the great
you carry that on yeah um when you were
named the head of the drink smart
axe smart uh campaign how did that go
down
yeah apart from the photo shoot where i
actually dressed smart i had a shave
had nice shoes and pants and a nice polo
on it didn't go too well to be fair
it was not great timing it was well kept
in new zealand
um we'd finish the season it was it was
good times and nelson two world cup
games i wasn't dressing smart and i
wasn't acting smart so
i caught a bit of heat from one the
police and to the union for a couple of
uh
nights out there where i probably wasn't
uh
you know dressing for acting smart
stressing nudes
mate we went it was quite cool for that
once that's right absolutely
we were in all sorts and yeah another
time i think i ended up down the main
street
doing them i know richard headley is
caught in
quite often happened after a night out
oh and tell the story about when you're
um
was it your auntie and uncle yeah
it was just after a court session at the
club rooms and uh
for some reason i had to do a nude bike
around the block
oh is that a punishment in the course in
the court session and came out of the
court session
i was just by myself it was random on a
bike no
biking round had a light stuffing right
down the
to the lights at fraga park or there was
an intersection where a car was stopped
so i stopped
and kind of at the back of the car my um
12-year-old cousin kind of just saw the
shock on her face
to see who cousin nude on the bike and
then my auntie and uncle just looking
around and being like and i'm just bited
off and said sorry and just kept on
going
keep down
[Laughter]
most memorable moment in the tap tap
jersey
most memorable mate i loved man i was
i loved club 40 hours i just used to
think it was like test match for the man
i used to
be uh writing one every morning on the
game but i used to love the noel barton
games and i used to love the nelson
marist games when marist had a really
strong team
whimera really strong used to go along
they used to be awesome games
good dancer um but you'd always have a
good night with your mouth it was some
of your best mates but
on the field it was like away used to
love those yeah nelson marist and the
wine merrill gaines for the for the um
noel barton because uh nobody was my
godfather so it was always a
big one for the family yeah john was
writing me for those games
notes yeah okay um
how did you break your nose
well it's happened a few times but the
worst one was my old mate shane grief
at uh broads
it wasn't much of a cricketer so he
wasn't much of a cricket so i'd give him
a little bit of a
little bit of leeway but he's i've gone
up we'll go up to the ball machine i'm
still playing i'm playing senior qriket
at this stage
i asked him to come up and throw a few
balls down for me in the ball machine
i've just got uh in there i put my my
brand new uh
gun and more glove on um i haven't faced
the ball yet
and he's put a ball in to see where it's
going to land the stick on a warm-up
ball
and the idiot's got it like right up and
he's called my name
as he's put this ball and known that
it's going to likely hit me to give me a
warning and i've looked up and it's hit
me square in the nose
on the full 115 or 120 clicks like this
dropped me
the doctor said i was lucky it hit me
screw on the nose or i could have been
yeah it could have
could have been a different story you
know in the eye or on the side of the
head or you know
so the old boonie was just shot like
that he rang mom
mom came up just followed the trail of
blood up to the hospital because
hospital's right next door was
not good and the worst thing is i had
urinary starting the next week so i went
down there looking like elephant man
single boy with big hopes of the first
week of o week at uni he had no chance
mate
no chance
oh classic okay
last question how can you be selected in
andrew goodman coached side this is for
from a player um
i like uh i like guys that work hard you
know yeah just
put team first um all those little
things like an ethan black header that
does all the little things that probably
go unnoticed by a little by a lot of
people yeah
diving on those hard balls chasing kicks
uh stuff we really pride ourselves on it
around our marco work
we call it a tasman or yeah we talk
about it then the crusaders around
caring as well so
just those little wacks if i see those
good attitude someone that's willing to
put the team first those are a couple of
key things
good answer oh what a story what a
journey
and some bloody good yarns in there
really appreciate you coming on the
wallet
podcast goodie you've obviously been a
massive part of my career
um you helped me out massively coming
out of school and getting
me to where i got to and it's been
awesome watching your journey
awesome reflecting on your journey and
it's awesome seeing you do so well
uh in the coaching scene at the moment
and i really looking forward to
following your journey hopefully
following right behind you on your
journey
and uh yeah looking forward to what's
ahead but yeah really appreciate you
coming on the water podcast
cheers jimmy appreciate it it's been
great to chat mate awesome
thanks mate real quick with christmas
just around the corner here's your
chance to purchase one of the three
great products mentioned at the start
firstly pure sport cbd this is a game
changer
for sleep muscle soreness anxiety you
name it can help with almost
anything it would be a great gift for
almost anyone
so to purchase go to puresportcbd.com
at the checkout put in whatalad20 in the
promo code
for 20 off also manscaped is another
great gift idea for anyone
who likes or needs to keep their body
hair maintained
there's some real great discounts on the
website already and you can get an
extra 20 off that price by entering what
a lad in capitals
in the promo code and this also includes
free
shipping last but not least fortune
favors beer is another great gift idea
for anyone who enjoys a craft beer
send them 24 of fortune favors finest
by going to fortune favors dot beer
and entering what a lad no spaces in the
promo code for 20
off